[Musik]
leider bietet dieses ende der woche doch
allerhand themen über die wir sprechen
müssen mit alexander graf lambsdorff dem
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
der fdp im deutschen bundestag
außenpolitiker alain graf lambsdorff
hallo hier zu sein
ich freue mich auch dass sie da sind
sich da nicht ein bisschen im stau schön
dass sie es geschafft haben und schön
dass ihre mitarbeiterin auch immer früh
aufgestanden ist die am eben gesagt die
hat ihnen das treffen von gestern noch
mal schön aufgearbeitet sozusagen also
was wird dieser möglicherweise diese
neuauflage des atomdeals tatsächlich
lösen und bewirken könnte also opfer da
hinkommen ist die große frage aber das
treffen gestern genauso wie der auftritt
von joe biden heute bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz der ganz starke
signale dass die usa auf europa setzen
in den gesprächen gestern ist
beschlossen worden die europäische union
soll im lied sein also soll die
gespräche mit dem iran führen russen
chinesen amerikaner rang holen und die
amerikaner haben ihrerseits das
rückabgewickelt was die administration
gemacht hat nämlich die sogenannten step
back sanktionen also diese automatischen
sanktionen die quasi deren kraft
getreten wären das ist ein signal an den
iran dass darf der iran jetzt nicht
verpassen
das ist die chance zurückzukehren an den
verhandlungstisch weil eines ist auch
klar innerhalb der beiden administration
gibt es unterschiedliche stimmen die ein
bisschen härter die anderen ein bisschen
konzilianter was das abkommen angeht
wenn der iran das jetzt ignoriert was
auf dem tisch liegt dann wird es sehr
schwer für joe biden sich in amerika
durchzusetzen mit einem verhandlung das
passt ja genau zudem dass der iran jetzt
angekündigt hat gestern das nächste
woche dienstag dann oder ab nächster
woche dienstag die inspektion
inspektoren der atomenergiebehörde nicht
mehr reingelassen würden wird es aus
ihrer sicht zu dieser eskalation kommen
oder wird er ihrer ansicht und das ist
genau der knackpunkt jetzt wenn am
nächsten dienstag die iaea inspektoren
nicht ins land gelassen werden dann wird
es für die amerikaner sehr schwer
angesichts der stimmung im kongress
angesichts der stimmung im land
insgesamt was den iran angeht in einen
verhandlungsprozess einzusteigen
deswegen ist der aufruf eindeutig nach
teheran
lasst die inspektoren rein lasst die
anlagen inspizieren das ist
das was jetzt kommen muss keine weitere
eskalation aber das ist schwierig weil
im iran hören wir da tobt ein machtkampf
im juni sind neue wahlen und offenbar
gibt es diesen machtkampf zwischen
hardlinern und reformen eher sind da
bleibt ja die frage wird er an der
tatsächlich jetzt ein link und auch
langfristig in anführungszeichen
einlenken weil die wirtschaftlichen
sanktionen das land so stark treffen
dass dort ist dem land aber so schlecht
geht dass man keine andere möglichkeit
hat oder wird genau das gegenteil
genau das ist die schlüsselfrage sie
haben völlig recht im iran ist es auch
nicht monolithisch als auch nicht alle
gleich und deswegen ist die ankündigung
der usa auch unter umständen bei den
sanktionen ein bisschen zurück zu gehen
und beispielsweise auch öl verkauft
wieder zuzulassen teilweise vom iran ja
wirtschaftlich ein signal in die
richtung dass man aus dem deal versucht
ein projekt zu machen von dem beide
seiten etwas haben der iran hat ja
bisher das gefühl er hat gar nichts von
diesen deal
und genau das ist der punkt an dem die
amerikaner jetzt ein neues signal
gesetzt haben das darf der iran nicht
verpassen
dann kommen wir einen schritt weiter zur
münchner sicherheitskonferenz die heute
nachmittag beginnen wird neues feuer hat
könnte man fast sagen 13 online statt
drei tagen münchen die kürzeste die es
wahrscheinlich so je gab
zum ersten mal mitten im us präsidenten
dabei ist natürlich auch einfach für ihn
weil es ist nur online in
anführungszeichen was können wir
erwarten von dieser münchner
sicherheitskonferenz außer diesen
auftritt von jobs also wolfgang
ischinger der chef der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz hat einen
irrsinnigen erfolg gelandet für die
konferenz aber ehrlich gesagt für
deutschland und für europa denn das ist
der erste große internationale auftritt
des neuen präsidenten der findet
sozusagen virtuell aber er findet in
münchen statt das ist schon mal toll
dass wirklich ein großer erfolg was wir
erwarten können sind glaube ich aussagen
zu den wirklich drei ganz großen themen
was sind die transatlantischen ziele das
sind klimaschutz sind sicherheit und
wohlstand klimaschutz seit heute sind
die usa wieder ein pariser abkommen ich
erwarte da impuls aus der rede
sicherheit ich glaube es wird so sein
dass auch joe biden und deutschen ins
stammbuch schreiben wird ihr müsst mehr
tun ihr müsst mehr verantwortung
übernehmen das ist ja keine trump idee
gewesen seit obama ja auch schon getan
der verantwortung militärischer natur
zweimal derart genau also dass wir
unsere verpflichtungen im bündnis
erfüllen
ich bin ja der meinung
wir raus müssen aus dieser rein
militärischen perspektive als fdp haben
wir gesagt wir wollen drei prozent also
für diplomatie
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und militär
und das ganze insgesamt betrachten aber
in die richtung müssen wir kommen und
das letztes wohlstand das sind über den
handelsfragen
ich hoffe dass es signale gibt dass die
amerikaner ihre willkür zölle der tramp
administration auf aluminium und stahl
jetzt zurücknehmen und ist das
realistisch ist das wahrscheinlich ich
bin nicht sicher ob das heute schon
kommen wird aber das ist ein punkt wo
wir wiederum den amerikanern sagen
müssen dass wir das erwarten denn
strafzölle sind zulässig die gibt es in
der handelspolitik immer aber willkür
zelle ohne jede rechtsgrundlage
das ist was anderes und deswegen müssen
die züge zurückgenommen da sind wir ja
auch grundsätzlich bei den
transatlantischen beziehungen sehr
gelitten habe in den letzten vier jahren
wo man sagte unter donald trump waren
sie wahrscheinlich noch nie so schlecht
mit deutschland zumindest ist es denn so
wie jetzt viele ja hoffen und viele
schon fast voraussagen dass die
beziehung sich deutlich ändern werden
oder ist es so wie viele kommentatoren
schreiben ist wird nur der ton sich ein
stück weit ändern aber die inhalte
bleiben
nein das werden sich auch die inhalte
ändern alleine die tatsache dass beiden
noch nicht mal einen monat nach
amtsantritt seine rede hält hier in
münchen ist ja schon eine klare änderung
und außerdem bild in der diplomatie ton
ist auch substanz also wie man
miteinander umgeht hat auch was damit zu
tun was man sozusagen an zielen
gemeinsam erreichen kann aber eines muss
man auch sagen
die bundesregierung tut zurzeit alles um
joe biden vors schienbein zu treten
erstens hält sie an nordstream 2 fest
ohne absprache mit den verbündeten also
wir sind da als deutschland ja völlig
isoliert in dieser frage in der
europäischen union gegenüber den
amerikaner
also da ist ein punkt wo die sicht aus
washington sehr kritisch ist und das
zweite ist die kanzlerin hat kurz vor
ende der deutschen ratspräsidentschaft
noch ein investitionsabkommen mit china
durch die europäische union abschließen
lassen
auch das sieht man in peking pardon und
das sieht man in washington extrem
kritisch könnte man nicht da ganz klar
sagen na ja das ist eben das interesse
der europäischen union das ist ein stück
weit auch die erwachsenen wäre damit man
sein möchte der eu und deutschland hatte
eben nur die ratspräsidentschaft das
ende des jahres inne und man hat eben
auch nur deutschland das zu geboten und
nur zugetraut ein abkommen mit china zu
zu schließen abgesehen davon dass es ja
eines der großen vorhaben der deutschen
bundesregierung während der
eu präsidentschaft war das mag so sein
aber erstens ist das abkommen ja viel
schmaler ausgefallen als man dachte weil
man den ganzen investitionsschutz nicht
drin hat nur den investitions zugang
eigentlich das ist also mit anderen
worten nicht ein comprehensive agreement
obwohl es so heißt punkt 1.2 nach der
portugiesischen präsidentschaft kommt
die französische und der kann man
durchaus auch zutrauen so etwas
hinzukriegen und dann hätte man es mit
den amerikanern abstimmen können so war
es ganz klar ein tritt vors schienbein
der neuen administration aus berlin
das anders gesprochen haben es nutzt
ring 2 diese ostsee gaspipeline zwischen
russland und der europäischen union die
sozusagen auch die die energiesicherheit
in europa sichern soll
da das wird heute auch thema sein da
sind die europäer ja fundamental anderer
meinung als die amerikaner auch als joe
biden also wenn dann der ehemalige
außenminister sigmar gabriel ich zitiere
das mal eben der ja auch vorsitzender
der atlantik brücke also eines
transatlantischen instituts ist wenn der
sagt das geht die usa ich zitiere das
erst mal gar nix an
ist das dann nicht mehr als vor
schienbein treten sondern eigentlich ein
klares zeichen dafür zu sagen wir haben
schon auch unsere eigenen interessen
wir haben auch unsere eigenen interessen
der mitte energiesicherheit europas hat
nord stream zwei ganz wenig zu tun der
bild wir haben die pipelines tiere über
land laufen durch polen und durch die
ukraine sind ja schon da es ist
sozusagen eine neue pipeline die ein
ziel hat und das ist die ukraine zu
isolieren die ukraine finanziell
auszutrocknen
und deswegen ist sie ein geopolitisches
projekt und nicht ein
energiewirtschaftliches und an einer
stellung und sich ihnen widersprechen
hier haben wir nicht eine 1 1 einen
unterschied zwischen europa und den usa
wir haben einen unterschied zwischen
deutschland und dem rest der welt also
die bald die skandinavier die polen die
ukraine selbst alle gegen dieses projekt
auch die franzosen sind eigentlich
dagegen auch wenn sie sich aus
deutsch-französischer disziplin ein
bisschen zurückhaltend mit harten
ansagen aber auch die sind eigentlich
dagegen also mit anderen worten
deutschland macht hier einen nationalen
alleingang und die amerikaner haben hier
praktisch den gesamten rest europas auf
ihrer seite plädieren sie deshalb dafür
dass man jetzt so zu sagen hut ab das
liegt also obwohl die und soll fast
alles fertig ist als fdp wollen wir
nicht eine große investitionsruine
schaffen also da milliardenschweres
investitionsgrad in der ostsee aber wir
brauchen jetzt ein moratorium einen
vorübergehenden baustopp bis russland
seine politik ändert und bis es eine
lösung gibt die dazu führt dass die
ukraine eben nicht die stabilisiert
nicht ausgetrocknet wird alexander graf
lambsdorff außenpolitiker der fdp vielen
dank hierfür besuch im studio bin froh
dass ich das geschafft habe ich ja auch
hier die erklärungen des tages gespräche
gerne